how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe
and one division episode 7 finally gave
us some answers as to what is kind of
happening in one division
and if you haven't seen one division
episode 7 or anything before that
here is your spoiler warning one
division episode 7 finally revealed that
it was agatha
all along
but one thing that fans were actually
kind of disappointed about is that
we heard that the last three episodes of
one division were going to be an hour
long
now when this news came out it was said
that kevin feige the president of marvel
studios said this
however i couldn't find the quote or
interview where he said this and then
episode 7 was not an hour long
and fans were kind of disappointed but
it does look like we know
the run time for episode 8 and possibly
the finale and on top of that we've got
some brand new photos of the falcon and
the winter soldier
so if you love to stay up to date on all
of the latest marvel news be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the videos
so sadly it seems like the next episode
of one division episode 8 isn't going to
be exactly an
hour long however it is going to be the
longest episode that we've gotten so far
right now episode 8 is reportedly going
to be 47 minutes long which would make
it the longest one division episode that
we've gotten so far
not yet an hour episode but there is
hope for the finale which i'll talk
about in just a bit
the run time is posted by reddit user
plenty underscore and chidna
underscore 544. now for the previous
episode this reddit user did post the
runtime for
episode 7. and it happened to be right
and the reddit user even got verified by
the mods on reddit which is pretty hard
to do so the credibility of this reddit
user has been verified and they are
stating that the next episode will be 47
minutes long
now the director of the one division
series matt shackman has revealed that
the entirety of the wanda vision series
should be
roughly six hours long now so far we've
gotten about four hours and 20 minutes
worth of one division air time
although not really because as we know
the credits kind of go for a while
but if you take into account the 47
minutes that episode 8 is supposed to be
that leaves an
hour for the finale of one division it
actually leaves us with a little bit
more than an hour
and one division episode 7 gave us a
post-credits scene
so we can assume that the finale will
give us one as well and it's nice that
the finale is going to be the longest
episode obviously that's where
everything is really going to go down
and paul bettany talked about a
crazy huge fight at the end that has
more cgi
than avengers end game had and that's a
lot of cgi but if you consider the fact
that we're going to have
two very powerful witches most likely
fighting each other and then you add the
fact that monica rambo has now gotten
her super power so she is either going
to be spectrum or
photon and will most likely join the
fight and then you have vision as well
we can definitely see how there is going
to be a
ton of cgi involved in this final battle
and of course we can't forget the huge
cameo that we still have not seen yet he
might be revealed in episode 8 but he'll
most likely be reserved for the grand
finale
and at this point in time there are
plenty of speculation and theories about
who this could be but whoever it is we
can certainly count on them having
powers
therefore adding to the huge fight scene
and the cgi involved
so it looks like 47 minutes for the next
episode of one division
and hopefully an hour or a little bit
over an hour for the grand finale
now today we got some brand new awesome
new photos from the falcon and the
winter soldier
and two of them involve sam holding
captain america shield
the first photo is clearly of a scene
that we've been shown in the trailer and
in certain promotionals
sam is seemingly wearing a pretty dark
suit which could imply that he was just
at the funeral of captain america and
this scene looks like he could have
either just
returned from the service or he's about
to go to the funeral
we have another one of him pulling the
shield out of the tree and we've seen
him throw the shield into the tree
several different times now in the
trailer and tv spots and we know from
the most recent falcon and the winter
soldier trailer that bucky is going to
be there as well
so this being a funeral for captain
america would make sense because that's
why both
sam and bucky would be there it could
also be the inauguration of
a new captain america that is neither
one of them but we'll have to wait and
see on that one
we then have a new photo of bucky and
sam fighting with sharon
carter we know that she's returning in
the falcon and the winter soldier and it
looks like she's going to be very very
involved we know that she was actually
on the run for helping sam bucky and
captain america
during civil war so she actually broke
the sokovia accords as well and could
even still be wanted right now
no doubt that she's been up to a lot
since the events of civil war
and hopefully we're going to see what
she's been up to in the falcon and the
winter soldier so let me know how
excited you are about the one division
finale and for the upcoming the falcon
and the winter soldier series that
starts just two weeks after the one
division series ends be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news be sure to like the
video and for a live
update you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof